welcome to this video I'm playing
caching caching from Sweden I play d4
for a change Bishop c5 the acid gambit
line here that's very interesting but I
forgot what to do exactly was i think
it's c3 c3 c3 queen beat 292 yeah i
think this this is so that is playing
very quickly interesting to be t5 looks
very strange why why why would you open
the position like that
he takes d5 playing night b3 yet this
looks very good for Wired maybe maybe a
night before you can play Queen B to but
this might be five this disaster cannot
take yeah man this position is just that
just terrible for black threatening
night b5 amongst others 96 hours also a
threat and he's ignoring everything ok
so light b5 is going back to the a this
is probably ok let's see 96 queen bee to
we are a Kazakh I can just take the rook
what are you doing after that just play
d4 maybe I take here Queen takes that's
not so convincing it's still very good
but probably not a win okay so play
deform and then i can i can actually
think about taking on g7 as well
queen yeah 84 was the only move really
now i can i can just take the rook I
think check yeah this kind of games you
always at listed checks to me I think
check what happened a lot to play one
year for as a kid you get those really
simple wins sometimes your people just
fail to complete development and stuff
ok he some he's able to to get the night
and at least material wise be a be
halfway ok but his king is still a big
problem let's see okay i think the
bishop on d6 is a very good very good
piece he might play quindi aid I need to
I need to get quick quickly to a sting
yeah I have Queen f3 queen age 5 stuff
like that but without the look i'm not
going to to win this game I need rook
here and maybe rook b1 b3 f3 or look C 1
C 3 both rocks needs to be need to be
lifted problem yeah I'll give this check
what now Queenie to or queen g4 could
utilize not bad just attacking it he's
playing without the look on h8 this is
the the main problem so let's see just
here and retreated now wait wait let's
consider for a moment if i play now we
can he cannot play age 5 g 6 is just
hanging and this means he doesn't really
have a move and threatening Roxy 7 but
if you if you have wide lens on the
seventh with the rook there should be
over
okay it seems that team he wants to
prepare it okay well this must be okay
each form plane should be five I guess
checking on f7 light f7 I can take and
turn yeah needs to play the smooth let's
see but just just play rook c8 isn't
this deadly you spin and now Bishop
should be six
still going on this game I probably
missing simple wins but what this just
at least wins I'm wins material ok check
Bishop takes on a quaint execution takes
for them
yeah 50 seconds now 14 it's not too
comfortable considering that I probably
should have made it a while ago check
yeah I'm attacking g7 so this is mostly
a tune to get a flight square for the
King gamma H bonus rather quick time
border check check
check check what the technical player
just very lucky that this was that this
was working check check check check mate
Wow yeah I may I really made life
difficult difficult for me wow I
shouldn't really get out of this but
maybe this isn't isn't so easy here I
don't think I have anything better I
mean maybe maybe I can take g7 now this
is even stronger but I'm not quite shown
at some let's check this yeah Bishop b5
is also strongly but this is this is
check check check this is probably
logical this also makes sense to me
activating the bishop you know check
yeah this is really should just win over
them I'm just letting above the hook
here rook c8 no wins yeah I rookie 6f is
a very big threat rook c8 is plus 8
probably if you let it run a while it
will give a given
you okay but this wins as well but I
really played this like a [ __ ] rook c8
is better than this it's slow inspector
oh wow I can just take the rook you can
just take the rook what tag ah I didn't
do that he didn't do that and now i can
take d 5 or what a blunder full game
check now looks you want a stronger yeah
one that this was crap wow I just I just
blundered blundered through p.m. that's
funny wow wow i guess i need to say i
need a break thanks for watching